i just want to be clear to the house
we do not have a vaccine yet but we are
one step closer there are many steps
still to take
the full safety data is not yet
available
and our strong and independent regulator
the mhra
will not approve a vaccine until it is
clinically safe
and until it's rolled out we won't know
how long the effect lasts for
or its impact not just on keeping people
safe
but also on reducing transmission
as deputy chief medical officer jonathan
van tam
said yesterday it's like the first goal
scored in a penalty shootout you haven't
won the cup yet
but it tells you that the goalkeeper can
be beaten
and beat this virus we must we can
and we will yesterday's announcement
marks an important step
step in the battle against covet 19.
but as the prime minister said we must
not slacken our resolve
and there are no guarantees and so it's
critical that people continue to abide
by the rules
and that we all work together to get the
r number
below one mr speaker if this or any
other vaccine is approved
we will be ready to begin a large-scale
vaccination program
first to priority groups as recommended
by the independent
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
before wide rolling it out more widely
our plans for deployment of a covet
vaccine
are built on tried and tested plans for
a flu vaccine
which we of course deploy every autumn
we do not yet know whether or when a
vaccine is approved
but i have tasked the nhs with being
ready
from any date from the 1st of december
the logistics are complex the
uncertainties are
real and the scale of the job is vast
but i know that the nhs brilliantly
assisted by the armed services
will be up to the task i can tell the
house that last night we wrote to gps
setting out 150 million pounds of
immediate support
and setting out what we need of them
working alongside hospitals and
pharmacies in preparing for
deployment the deployment of the vaccine
will involve
working long days and weekends
and it comes on top of all the nhs has
already done for us
this year and i want to thank in advance
my nhs colleagues
for the work that this will entail i
know
that they will rise to this challenge of
being ready
when the science comes good to inject
hope
into millions of arms this winter